a lot of people are speculating about
where Brent goes with his metal career
you know a lot of this is a satanic oh
really and you know I got to wondering
where is it all gonna lead will Brent
end up in the Church of Satan will he
end up a full metalhead worshiping
Aleister Crowley and these various other
people what will happen to Brent the
future so what we have done right now is
we're gonna get in a time machine Rob
we're going forward we've invented a
time machine we're gonna go forward in
time and meet the Brent of the future
okay and find out how deeply involved
with Satan he is now and here we go
everyone hold on to your hats if you
look at your screen Robin you will see
Brent in the future absolutely man yep
pleasure transmit entertainment with you
from the net Brent to the Future I'm
looking at you and you're wearing a what
looks like a priest outfit oh that's
this just my casual attire man yep this
is what I wear every day but what is
going on are you ice full save Marsha
purr and who is mocking the church no
actually I still love Church just not
the Church of Satan I love the Church of
the Lord
praise God praise the Lord I thought you
were an atheist what what changed in
your life that you are now
no man well I came around to realizing
that all this like swinging an anger man
it was just a reconciled regressive
repression Oh
go back to my Bible Belt roots and take
up faith right so you so what we've
learned by going in the future is that
Brent does not go the way of Satan he's
into the Lord you're into the Lord oh I
love it man and you and you love Jesus
and and everything I praise the Lord man
me and my wife were a pretty late last
night man we were making signs for the
pro-life rally coming up yep oh wow
you're pro-life
oh yeah it's like Dan clusen Dorf wrote
a fetal heartbeat can be detected five
and a half to six weeks after gestation
and what about you and Caitlyn do you
swing anymore is that over oh not at all
hey sister Caitlin come say hi to the
old Brent Oh send her Caitlin's nursing
her baby Abraham's Wow and she no longer
swings with Brent no oh man we actually
have 17 kids now we have Abraham Luke
Matthew Adam Eve Jeremiah yep well I
Isaiah Nathaniel John Noah Zachary yep
my rent is shocked by your own future
this is could you app ridiculous
I hate this more than Rapaport actually
your wife is dressed as a nun you are
dressed as a priest you have 17 children
you believe in God and you are against
abortion how did this all happen I mean
what point did you turn well by the
grace of God I found salvation gave up
this ridiculous rebellious rib and I'll
never forget the night that I found God
I remember it like it was yesterday we
went to Steamies in Tampa yep right
swingers club
origen wall-to-wall beaver blasting pump
deal shut the walls chakra closed all
the sudden Makai lost control of his
load I couldn't get some load shrapnel I
looked down and there it was
I saw the image of the Virgin Mary in
his load it was a sign from God to give
up this life of sin and devote my life
to faith Wow well Brent of the future I
can't wait to show this on the app we
just saw no we saw the Brent took it
took a load right on his face yeah man
and it's like they say in Corinthians 13
through thy storm is thy light of
salvation and Brent to the Future you're
completely out of metal music now you're
not part of that community oh no I'm
still a metalhead man but I'm a
Christian metalhead alright
oh yeah you know I worked up from
subdeacon to deacon yep to priest and
now that I live here in Waynesboro
Mississippi back to the Bible Belt roots
and well I love it here at the Church of
st. Matthew well I see a time machine is
running down Brent to the future so
we're gonna have to go back to Brent of
the past absolutely really quick do you
want to meet my Christian metal band
sure yep we are iron Eucharist
one two amen renounce the devil and take
up faith worship God don't give in to
snakes
gotta be nice must be holy praise the
Lord like Joel Osteen hold your Bible
real high and pray to Christ as you know
he's right pray to Christ cuz you know
by brentd the future good to talk to you
pal and I approved the Lord's message
thank you Wow
well I can't implement wait for the
future